person's secrets death and desire at
Monticello programs an hour good evening
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Penn
bookstore on this chilly evening I'm
very pleased to have Andrew bursting
with us
Andrew Burstein is a full professor and
co holder of the Mary Frances Barnard
chair in US history at the University of
Tulsa
he was consultant to Ken Burns and
appears in the PBS documentary Thomas
Jefferson his scholarly articles on
Jefferson have been published in the
nation the william and mary quarterly
and the journal of the early republic
Burstein is the author of the passions
of Andrew Jackson America's Jubilee and
the inner Jefferson please join me in
welcoming Andrew Burstein good evening
Thomas Jefferson and his generation paid
as much attention to the life of the
body as they did more famously to the
life of the mind
so Jefferson's secrets is a book about
appetites and desires it is a history of
Thomas Jefferson in his world and I
spend less attention or have only a
secondary concern with the expectations
of our world when we talk about 18th
century morality it's not the same as
21st century morality when we talk about
Jefferson as a liberal racist it's it's
not a necessarily a contradiction if he
had sex with a servant he did so because
it was not considered immoral in his
time and this is largely a function of
the medical literature that he owned and
read and responded to and that's what my
talk tonight is going to focus on
Jefferson of course is one of the most
scrutinized figures in American history
so I haven't historians by now uncovered
just about all there is to understand
a Thomas Jefferson's life and my answer
to that is no we have not
there are essential questions that are
yet unresolved where did his passion
come from how did he wish to be
remembered how did he confront his own
mortality
the research that I've done for this
book concentrates on not exclusively but
in large measure on Jefferson's
retirement papers these are not
published
fortunately the the first volume of
Jefferson's retirement papers he was
retired from the presidency in 1809 and
he lived another 17 years dying at the
age of 83 in 1826 but most of his
retirement years have been ignored even
by some of our best historians or
focusing on his founding of the
University of Virginia which opened in
1825 the year before he died perhaps
some here are familiar with Jefferson's
feelings about the Missouri Compromise
in 1820 which extended slavery to the
west and showed him as a southern
partisan and opposed to the young and
growing abolitionist movement but by and
large Jefferson's retirement papers are
unpublished at this time and here is
where I've gleaned more information
about the inner Jefferson because he is
less self-centered
excuse me less self-censoring in his
retirement papers than in the papers
that have been published that deal with
his political prime so there is in all
he wrote a meaningful language of
nervous sensation of imaginative
sympathy profound feeling starting in
the Declaration of Independence
Jefferson uses a language that draws us
to him but we don't quite understand its
context he describes the course
human events as a very visceral and very
human experience he refers to the
British as unfeeling brethren he divides
human impulses in into really a mind
that is either compassionate or
unfeeling and he would later divide
political parties in this way the
Federalists his political opposition the
political conservatives of his time he
saw in pathological terms his Liberal
Democratic Republicans were men of he
said compassionate feeling and the
opposition Federalists who were afraid
to sympathise with the people he called
unfeeling and ungenerous and disordered
or in his words diseased in the
imagination so these terms that he uses
we should reflect upon in the
declaration he says the nation is
exposed to invasions from without and
convulsions within wherever there is a
crisis at any time in his political life
Jefferson isolates nervous convulsions
in 1776 it was loyalist forces producing
convulsions within the body politic but
I said it's in his later years that such
language intensifies in 1816 when he was
73 he wrote there are i acknowledged
even in the happiest life some terrible
convulsions he and the medical writers
of his generation referred to the male
sexual impulse in similar terms the
spasm the convulsive reaction the
convulsions and tremors that precede
seminal excretion these are the
convulsions he said shared by all animal
life the medical thinkers that Thomas
Jefferson read and responded to equated
sex with male health health of the
nervous system bodily balance avoiding
excess passions part of regiment of self
control of self-monitoring
and productivity the medical
enlightenment that jefferson subscribed
to accepted that nerves were invisible
and mysterious and potentially
devastating and nerves formed a powerful
connection between the brain and the
soul so when delicate women read novels
that were too romantic or too
adventurous they would throw their
nerves out of balance that's the way
Jefferson and many of the men of his
generation saw such novels that women
read Jefferson wrote that he felt that
women would suffer a bloated imagination
and a sickly judgment by reading such
books doctors described women who died
after giving birth as having succumbed
to the overactive imagination and that
and uncontrolled nerves so that if they
hadn't let their nerves get out of
balance they wouldn't have died in
childbirth physicians referred to
something called uterine fury women who
could not control the passions emanating
from their body so Jefferson believed
that women had to be modest and passive
and men had to protect women from
themselves and he didn't make this up
this was part of what was known as the
medical enlightenment the standard
reading medical texts of his day so for
Jefferson as a physiologist as a medical
thinker or responsive to medical
thinking there is an essential division
in his perspective on a man's act of
life that division was between
convulsive passions or outward
aggression and tranquil Felicity
healthful measured affection
sincerity manly firmness emotional
balance that was the dichotomy that he
saw at the end of Jefferson's
Declaration of Independence after what
he calls the last stab to agonizing
affection which is again a potent
painful image he asserts that America
has no recourse but to renounce forever
these unfeeling brethren America's
independence was a separation from the
British who were unfeeling brethren
again in his first inaugural addresses
as president he contrasted his
progressive modern outlook with the
throes and convulsions of the ancient
world the agonizing spasms of infuriated
man I mean we love this language but we
never stopped to consider where it comes
from and it comes from the medical
thinking of his time he's always keeping
to the language of nervous sensations
the body's vulnerability concerns him in
1816 in his retirement he describes his
relationship to the corporeal
inhabitants of the corporeal globe but
even positive passions political
enthusiasm had to be moderated under the
medical thinking of this time
Jefferson's good friend dr. Benjamin
Rush who we all know here in
Philadelphia
wrote of the excess passion for Liberty
even too much of a love for Liberty was
a bad thing for medical thinkers and
politicians sensitive to this language
rush wrote of nerves bent and twisted
and out of control and called it a
species of insanity this excess love of
Liberty
so nerves could carry a healthy
excitement the sympathetic treatment of
ordinary people that jefferson is known
for is a Democrat but nerves could also
contain seeds of disorder personal
disorder public
disorder
when Jefferson referred again to the
Federalist Party to his political
opposition and he was a bitter partisan
for his whole life he identified these
political enemies as carriers of
lethargic nerves Federalists were not
only anti Republicans or office holders
as he categorized them but also in his
words nervous persons whose language
nerve fibers have more analogy with a
passive than active state of things so
impaired nerves and bodily deficiencies
made the Federalists afraid of social
progress that's how Thomas Jefferson saw
his political world and curiously too it
is from medicine from science and not
from religion that he derived his moral
judgments he said good sense in the
spirit underlying a love of Liberty are
life-affirming natural phenomena bigotry
he described literally as a disease so
from the throes and convulsions of the
ancient world and the agonizing spasms
of infuriated man we move to what my
book examines in great detail which is
the emotional aspects of the controversy
surrounding Thomas Jefferson and Sally
Hemings a woman he owned his slave I'm
going to move now from
eighteenth-century neurophysiology to
race relations and the sexual
imagination because it's all part of the
same fabric writing about black and
white tensions in his notes on Virginia
the only book that Jefferson ever
authored in his lifetime his pose was
again that of a physiologist he
expressed the fear of I quote the
extermination of one or the other race
he explained that when deep-rooted
prejudices held by whites came face to
face with the ten thousand recollections
held by viciously exploited blacks it
was and what word the Jefferson choose
convulsions that would provoke the
catastrophic race war
that he foresaw sometime in America's
future if a solution to the race problem
were not found but what was it that
triggered his use of the word
convulsions here his next thought
informs us color of the skin color of
the blood color of the bile or some
other secretion so it's important that
in this discussion relating to sex
across the color line he was drawn to
consider bodily fluids racial
comparisons of Beauty mixtures he said
expressions of every passion again I
can't stress enough Jefferson dwelled on
carnal life there is an incisive 'no
stand a hardiness to him when he writes
about the body and in retirement in
defining himself against these other
kinds of men those lethargic men that he
described he added such words as gloomy
and hypochondriac minds diseased bodies
disgusted with the present hypochondriac
was characterized at this time as
diseased in the imagination and it meant
men who lacked the ability to control
their passions it wasn't just women
who's nervous constitutions needed to be
balanced it was men as well so how could
Jefferson rationalize maintaining a
healthy body
promoting a healthy nervous system and
at the same time crossing the color line
to father children with his slave isn't
that losing control of his passions or
in his terms
isn't that a diseased imagination and
the answer shockingly is no because the
medical literature of Jefferson's time
that he read consistently instructed him
instructed men of letters the Jean de
letra since it was mostly French writers
whom he was reading that sedentary
person sedentary intellectuals who sat
at their desks who read who write upper
class at elections had to do as follows
here's the prescription maintain a
semi-vegetarian diet
exercise daily as on horseback in
Jefferson Road up to eight or nine miles
a day even into his late 70s and early
80s and three have regular sex with a
healthy attractive fruitful female it
didn't have to be one's wife Jefferson
was a widower
his wife Patti died in 1782 when he was
39 years old he never remarried
this was an acceptable solution without
remarriage so we know that he ate little
meat he favored the semi-vegetarian diet
we know that he rode his horse several
miles a day we know he took great
interest in monitoring his bodily
functions and so the medical
enlightenment did not say you couldn't
have sex with someone other than your
wife we associate too often the
Victorian morality with the
revolutionary generation but they
preceded the Victorian age men like
Jefferson understood they could rule
their own sex lives
this was masculine authority masculine
prerogative he knew about sex across the
color line certainly in in Virginia
across color and class lines he knew
about rape on southern plantations so
when you add to this assessment his
perception that Sally Hemings whom he
knew from her infancy she was the same
age as Jefferson's oldest daughter Sally
Hemings for him was not one-quarter
black but three-quarters white
he was providing for the economic
well-being of his extramarital offspring
and that was within the bounds of
morality as his community defined it he
thought of the Hemings family as a
parallel subordinate family and they
were related to Jefferson directly
through his wife through her father his
father-in-law was Sally Hemings his
father
so this parallel subordinate family were
not for Jefferson generic black people
he knew precisely how much blood of what
race coerced through them and so they
were more than a register of skin color
for him it was only the the satirist of
the north
Jefferson's Federalist enemies who chose
to darken Sally Hemings his skin
pigmentation they had never seen her but
they transformed her into what they
called the African Venus in their ironic
poetry and they did this to embarrass
Jefferson but what we don't quite fathom
is his full emotional response to the
satire and to the relationship that he
would not own up to withholding it
apparently from his own grandchildren so
the intriguing question that were left
with is why he was embarrassed to talk
to his family about this but the rest of
the the other questions the essential
questions we can answer through an
appreciation of 18th century health
science and what was once sound medical
advice and the fact that men at this
time even founders had sex with people
they weren't married to if they were
discreet they were not judged
Jefferson has always been described on
the basis of his body language he was
called reserved and a bit shy the
opposite of say the vain self-obsessed
hyper-masculine Alexander Hamilton his
chief political opponent in the 1790s
and Hamilton's extramarital sex life is
much better documented Hamilton called
Jefferson and James Madison weak willed
and womanly Jefferson had his own
definition of masculinity for him it was
connected to the brain not to acts of
military courage or sexual boastfulness
but a body language of outward reserve
and a mentally engineered bodily control
does not mean Jefferson was celibate
either Madison is perhaps the most
asexual of the founders but he was also
very likely a sexually active man before
he married Dolly Todd Dolly Madison
married him when he was over 40 and we
know nothing about James Madison's
sexual experience before 40 but somehow
he doesn't arouse the same interest as
Thomas Jefferson does Madison
unsuccessfully courted a 15 year old
girl when he was in his mid-30s which
was okay back then reminding us that we
should not transpose our own sexual
values to the founding generation and
it's possible that James Madison also
bedded with prostitutes before he met
dolly prostitution was the occupation of
somewhere between five and eight percent
of American women in Philadelphia in the
early 19th century so while I repeat
there is no direct evidence of this of
Madison sexual activity absence of
evidence does not equal celibacy and
prostitution was quite common just
another quick example Charles charles
cotesworth pinckney who ran against
thomas jefferson for the presidency in
1800
was found with a prostitute in a
Washington DC house when he was in his
mid-70s my point is that the founders
were of a class and of a generation that
had fewer qualms about sex than we
retrospectively imagined but I don't
want to suggest that we should have a
tabloid fascination with the founders
that's not at all where I'm going with
this book I'm trying to help readers
understand Jefferson and sexuality in
the context of the great medical minds
of his day and as I mentioned earlier
the Swiss and the French were perhaps
stronger influences in America than the
English and stronger on Jefferson he
owned everything written in English and
French by dr. Samuel Auguste David T so
T so was the Alfred Kinsey of
Jefferson's generation he developed more
or less an aesthetic by which members of
the intelligentsia could select a sexual
partner T so referred to the general the
genital licker the essential oil the
most perfect and important of all the
aminal animal liquors
this was semen which he thought
supported one's nervous Constitution the
suddenness of ejaculation the loss of
the vital fluid at the moment of
excitement caused a change within the
male body that required replenishment so
for this reason he was sternly opposed
to onanism which is what masturbation
was called at this time or a moderate
sexual activity which weakened the
nerves caused melancholy the word that
they most often used and often also led
to suicide
so Jefferson's taking of Sally Hemings
as a concubine would have offered him a
nearby sexual outlet fulfilling dr. T
cells call for urgent
activity on the part of men who needed
to protect their bodies
he even asserted that one like Jefferson
could further justify the correctness of
his course as a sexual being because
spermatic fluid he said was as healthy
for the female who received it as it was
unhealthy for the man who wasted it
through masturbation his servants
exclusive attention to him would also
have protected Jefferson against
venereal disease which was quite common
quite prevalent in his time in fact
Jefferson's doctor at the end of his
life a man by the name of Thomas Watkins
thought that Jefferson might have
contracted gonorrhea as a younger man
and that had recurred and caused him an
enlarged prostate and pain in urination
which is what he was suffering from at
the end of his life so in the context in
which he lived based on the health
science that Jefferson studied a
monogamous relationship with Sally
Hemings his servant did not have to
represent a loving commitment but rather
her implicit agreement to safeguard his
sexual health and I'm not saying that he
didn't have fond feelings for her we
don't know we can't know and nobody in
the inside of Monticello ever spoke
about it
but what I am saying is that if he lived
according to the habit habits widely
recommended by the doctors of his time
to man of his social class then as a
widower who was meant to have regular
sexual activity in order to preserve his
mental health and preserve his very life
then Jefferson certainly could have
rationalized the sex life that we assume
he enjoyed but which was unequal and
looks perhaps immoral to modern critics
so when Jefferson's political opposition
mocked him when they wrote stories about
Sally Hemings the African Venus they
weren't mocking him because they thought
he was engaging in immoral behavior they
mocked him because he was being an
ordinary man that the very philosophical
very presidential Thomas Jefferson was
merely an ordinary man with ordinary
tastes and ordinary desires he wrote of
slavery critically as a system that
encouraged boisterous passions again
we're back to the language of passions
and so generation by generation
boisterous passions would increase and
cause an imprint on the imaginations of
white tyrants and black resistors and at
the same time Jefferson insisted that
black and white should not and could not
live together because he said of
physiological differences and he thought
he could discern those differences
blacks he said secrete less from the
kidneys and more by the glands of the
skin which gives them a very strong and
disagreeable odor in imagination they
are dull tasteless and anomalous more
ardent after their female but love seems
with them to be more an eager desire
than a tender delicate mixture of
sentiment and sensation their griefs are
transient
many have been critical of Jefferson for
this bogus science but this bogus
science was not original with Jefferson
he was deeply immersed in medical
studies and as faulty and as dangerous
as his conclusions are they show how
reliant he was on the leading voices of
18th century medicine and yet even in
putting Jefferson in this context I feel
it is still appropriate for us to pass
some judgment upon him and to consider
him the father or a father of black
disillusionment because he could have
grown over time there was contrary
evidence to the medical evidence that he
drew upon but for him to conclude that
blacks were prosaic and not a poetic
people by nature was a distinct failing
in Jefferson because there was ample
evidence that he was wrong
even in his own time even in the age of
slavery but he wanted the sexual
frontier between black and white to be
walled off I found a letter of 1813 and
it's a letter that's been published
since the 19th century but nobody is
thought to look carefully at this letter
from Jefferson to Adams he's 70 years
old Jefferson sitting at Monticello
pondering the future pondering the
future of the human species and he's
thinking of ancient Greek poet
philosophers by the names of the Agnes
of Megara and oselas Lucas whom
virtually nobody knows today but their
notions of bloodlines and sexuality
meant a lot to men like Jefferson and
Adams in this letter Jefferson concludes
that unless artificial boundaries were
put in place sexual chemistry would take
over and the desire of society for the
best and brightest and strongest to
marry to mate would be impossible he
acknowledged in his words that natural
attraction ruled that the earth was
increasingly being populated not by any
plan but by and I quote the fortuitous
concourse of breeders sex happened
that's what he was saying
the fortuitous concourse of breeders so
he thought blacks were physically
unattractive and not meant to mate with
whites but if he was honest with himself
he knew that physical attraction would
ultimately rule and that America would
become what the historian Clarence
Walker is calling a mongrel nation
natural attraction ruled
so Jefferson knew that interracial sex
was inevitable and yet he disparage
black Americans and felt that the most
liberal and humane solution and I do
believe that this is what he truly felt
was to recolonize blacks outside the
borders of the United States to deport
them a mass deportation and Jefferson
was not alone in this it was possible
during his lifetime to cast this policy
in humane terms the American
Colonization Society was founded in 1816
during Jefferson's retirement and it did
just that it returned a small number of
freed black Americans to Africa to build
ostensibly an american-style Republic
the sentimental rhetoric of the members
of the American Colonization Society and
they included such statesmen as James
Madison and Henry Clay the rhetoric
called this return to Africa the return
of lost souls reuniting black Americans
with their cultural past the American
Colonization Society ignored the
patriotic objectives of free blacks in
the United States who wanted nothing
other than social respect and eventual
political equality so when Jefferson was
thinking about walling off the sexual
frontier between his white nation in the
lost black nation he was not as I
alluded to earlier thinking of the
hemings's
in terms of their skin pigmentation and
we must understand that in his flawed
scientific mind the percentage of
whiteness correlated with intellectual
capacity in Jefferson's mind the
mixed-race hemings's were not tainted
again to use the terms he used they were
light skinned for good reason they were
part of his family they were members of
the laboring class who were part of his
family
and he didn't classify them with the
anonymous multitudes of blacks across
the south who's credible resentments
toward the planters who enslaved them he
feared and other fat other planters
feared the large extended Hemings family
was Jefferson's special responsibility
and he knew them as intimates he was
Squire Jefferson and they came with the
manor the property that he tried to keep
fruitful and productive and dynamic he
trained them as artisans Sally's
children could melt into white society
if they chose well there is no
historical evidence that Sally Hemings
his voice was ever heard at Monticello
she was Jefferson's concubine not his
substitute wife as some have claimed she
was dressed as a servant because she was
a servant she was not masquerading as a
servant we cannot know precisely the
degree of emotional connection between
the master and the servant but her power
over Jefferson was negligible he did not
fear her what she might say or do
he did not emancipate her even upon her
death apparently he did not even teach
her to read because the only reliable
record we have in this sense is Madison
Hemings the daughter of Sally Hemings
and presumably Thomas Jefferson who was
born in 1805 and who was an old man
after the Civil War recounted something
of his early life
he said that Jefferson showed little
affection for him and his siblings and
he said that he had to induce
Jefferson's grandchildren to teach him
how to read and write and so I infer
from this that Sally Hemings could not
teach him to read and write
so it doesn't sound to me that Sally
Hemings was the substitute wife of
Thomas Jefferson
it would be nice if Jefferson were open
and progressive and ahead of his time
and was able to love a woman who was
part black love a woman who was a
servant and there were southern planters
who did but not Thomas Jefferson I think
it's unrealistic for us the evidence
does not support such a conclusion
I think the evidence does support the
conclusion the Jefferson's careful
attention to bodily health caused him to
agree with dr. T so and others that
celibacy was unhealthy and even
dangerous for a sedentary intellectual
like himself and so a healthy attractive
fruitful female like Sally Hemings and
by the way dr. T Silla and the other
doctors of the time felt that having sex
with a pretty woman and Sally Hemings
was always described as pretty the
African Venus having sex with a pretty
woman was healthier than having sex with
an ugly woman men were in charge of
their sex lives as they were in charge
of ordering their business lives the
only moral distinction is that it was
customary not to make one sexual
activity part of one's public portfolio
so as a reader of medical treatises
Jefferson was familiar with the role of
sex in maintaining a healthy balance of
the body's internal forces of keeping
one's neurophysiology in check sex was
part of a regimen of self-control and
important for a man to understand if he
was to enjoy a productive life
Jefferson strived for better health in a
medically primitive environment through
what he called an equilibrium of all the
passions he sought and hoped for what he
called tranquil permanent Felicity that
was his pursuit of happiness so what
temptation am i leaving you with we
don't know Jefferson as well as we
imagine we do just as in portraits of
him we see the portrait painter perhaps
as much as we see the subject Americans
are brought up to cherish Thomas
Jefferson's words without knowing the
full context of his words and without
really knowing why we cherish him my
book tries to address such questions by
giving him greater corporeal substance
placing him within a world of appetites
in a world of personal power
the goal is one I I know we all share
and that is to try to tell the truth
about our history thank you I'm happy to
take any questions if you have any yeah
um you seem to have moved somewhat in
your sense of Sally Hemings from your
earlier book the inner Jefferson to this
one what made you go back and you were
sort of a little skeptical of some of
the evidence faun Brody and so forth
what made you go back and what what if
eventually changed your mind into seeing
the the rationale for these arguments as
you say it was more than strictly DNA
where I presume right I had I had
problems with with both explanations and
I I do go into that in this book too
I felt that the Jefferson family denial
which persisted until the DNA evidence
which indicated which didn't indicate
but which emphasized that the Carr
brothers Jefferson's nephews frequented
the slave quarters and were the real
fathers one or the other of them were
both of them of Sally Hemings as
children there was anecdotal evidence to
support this but the Jefferson family
denial seemed until DNA as no less
credible than the African American oral
history which was passed down from the
slave community at Monticello and part
of the problem is that some of that oral
history has been disproved one of the
families that trace the lineage to
Jefferson and Sally Hemings has been
proven by DNA not to be biologically
linked but the cars have been
definitively excluded so DNA says that a
Jefferson fathered Sally hemings's
children or at least
Eston Hemings the last son born in 1808
Jefferson's last year as president I was
troubled what I wrote the inner
Jefferson that Jefferson's daughter
never explained to her children the
truth of Sally Hemings his conceptions
she grew up with Sally Hemings
there was no way that she didn't know
the truth why did she deny the truth
when history wanted to know and her
children were going to be responsible
for protecting Thomas Jefferson's legacy
so there is that absence of information
that was troubling but before there was
DNA evidence it was it was hard to know
for certain
looking at the competing evidence I
decided to have a look at this again
because even after DNA DNA tells us
factually what may have occurred but it
says nothing about emotions and so in
America today or since 1998 there really
are two extreme beliefs either Jefferson
loves Sally Hemings and she was his
substitute wife or she was his slave and
he raped her and what I'm suggesting is
that the medical books on Jeffersons
shelves and the language that he drew
from the world of Medicine offer us
greater insight into emotional
considerations and help us get a more
realistic picture where we're not
looking to destroy Jefferson's
posthumous reputation we're not looking
to make sure he remains on a pedestal
among the founders the great men but to
try to find what the truth was and as
far as I know this is the first attempt
by a historian since the DNA results
were published to get behind this
problem and look more fully at the
historical context yes
I was curious about Jefferson's
relationship with his wife I've heard
that she died of diabetes I don't know
if that's true if you have any
information
and would if he felt resentful of her
based on his the theories of medicine
that you outlined would have he you know
just looked down on her that because
they wouldn't understand why she had
this lingering disease uh there is no
direct historical evidence no
documentary evidence to suggest that
patty Jefferson had diabetes it is well
there's very little to go on
she was she was physically petite and
not strong in constitution and she had
trouble in several of her pregnancies
she died at the end of her sixth
pregnancy and this was not all that
unusual in this medically primitive time
but Jefferson knew of his wife's
physical condition and if he was if he
was worried about her frailty he could
have refrained from getting her pregnant
time and again
but again I think he's he's he's
reacting to the culture of his time and
he didn't have any sons he was important
for a man in his position to father sons
and perhaps that explains why despite
the difficulty that she had in her
pregnancies she continued to get
pregnant the only other thing I could
say about that is that by every
indication they had a very loving
relationship and Jefferson was a
sentimentalist he fell apart he broke
down when she died and he was insensible
to the world as his daughter wrote in
the weeks after Patti Jefferson's dying
they in terms of medical knowledge they
knew about contraception so there would
have been a means of maintaining a
healthy intimacy without her getting
pregnant but I think that's really all
we can say about about patty Jefferson
there's very little information about
her life on this gentleman mentioned dr.
farm Brodie and a doctor Brodie brought
a book back in the 1970s and one of the
important points that she brought out or
agreed with was the UH the history that
was recorded in 1802 September 1st 1802
in the Richmond recorder newspaper where
the news newsman James Callender
said to Thomas Jefferson had a concubine
named Sally Sally had a child named Tom
that Tom was ten or twelve years old and
looked like the president was the
president's son you choose and Madison
Hemings who you mentioned said that his
mother was pregnant when she came back
from France with Jefferson I'm very
concerned about the standards that
Jeffersonian historians used to
interpret this this history and in your
book your new book which is a different
version of this history in your previous
book but in your new book you said that
there's no record of a child being born
before 1796 so although there was a
million American to probably you know it
were four million Americans at the time
and maybe a million of when literate and
probably that million knew about this
controversy but you don't choose to
share with your readers in 2005 with the
entire literate American population new
in 1802 about this I find that troubling
well let me let me let me try to answer
your question well let me I might look
before you answer let me yeah the one
that troubles me most as Thomas
Jefferson wrote what they called a farm
book and you know as I know that the
farm book has been desecrated and
mutilated and the way I look at the
history of Jeffersonian historians right
I think they build foundations of
certain parts of this history upon the
fact that the book has been mutilated
and certain pages have been torn out and
certain names and words have been
eliminated and no Jefferson Sawney and
historian has ever complained about the
mutilation or desecration of the book
and I've read you know Joe Ellis and you
and nobody acknowledges it happen and
nobody has condemned it I'm concerned
about the continued renovation of a
marchello mansion I think that these
things if they're acknowledged maybe
maybe our history won't physically
disappear well Monticello first of all
has been doing a tremendous job in
airing all sides and seeking the truth
the mutilation of the farm book is
something I'm not altogether familiar
with I can say that I base what I write
about what's in the book is what's
available to me and it's true Madison
Hemings reported and he is at
in most other ways that his mother
became pregnant shortly before leaving
Paris and that Thomas Jefferson was the
father of this child but the Tom that is
referred to in calendars report all the
scholars I know of every persuasion
believed that this person was fabricated
that there is no Tom and calendar was
not right about everything so the other
question that you asked about concerns
the the response by Americans literate
Americans add to calendars accusations
in 1802 and 1803 there was that period
of time 1802 1803 where the satirist had
a good time making fun of President
Jefferson they were they weren't really
interested in Sally Hemings no one was
really interested in her feelings or who
she was or what she was like this was a
way of getting back at someone with whom
they disagreed politically I have read
almost nothing in the archives
concerning ordinary Americans responding
to the satires and to calendars
inferences and charges one thing I did
come across which no one has ever
spotted before was a letter that
Jefferson received near the end of his
life in 1823 I believe from a man who
worked closely with calendar and who
apologized for being associated with a
man who in his inebriated expostulations
or something along these lines calendar
was was
reputedly an alcoholic and drowned in
the James River the year after the the
accusations were levelled so the man who
was apologizing to Thomas Jefferson is
having at one time been an associative
calendars
wasn't saying that I know his charges to
be untrue he was saying the calendar was
a bad man for saying what he said and
that's something different but I wish I
could answer your several questions more
to your satisfaction but you know in all
candor I've dug as deep as possible to
find in the unpublished manuscripts what
might give us insights into Jefferson's
in her life and into Sally hemings's
relationship to him and and to her role
at Monticello and there's little to go
on and so I don't want to speculate
beyond what is reasonable and I've tried
to present tonight what I think is a way
of understanding the context better but
unfortunately there there are some
aspects of this history that we may
never know yes
speaking on your terms about his
physiological and medical purposes of
having this relationship with Sally my
question also well what I'm trying to
question is about the economic value of
him having children through Sally
Hemings considering the fact that at
that time breeding was a popular way of
maintaining an economic workforce on the
plantation
he had no values to that as as well
Jefferson was a southern planter and as
such he did in his correspondence refer
to a woman whom he was for example going
to purchase from a friend in a
neighboring County referred to her as
well she's no longer breeding so yes a
price was put on on slaves and slave
women and Jefferson did speak that
language
he drew yeah that's what I was getting
he did not look at Sally in that
perspective because the hemings's came
to him through John Wayles through his
father-in-law and that whole family he
felt special responsibility to when he
wrote to Sally's brother John Hemings
who was a carpenter and Jefferson's eyes
and ears of in his poplar forest
plantation in Bedford County Virginia
Jefferson wrote to him with warmth
concern for his well-being and also what
I see is significant he put his
correspondence in the file and in what's
called the summary Journal of letters
which was Jefferson's record of all
letters sent and received with man of
substance with elite white men and he
included some of his letters with John
Hemings in that same file so
that says something symbolic to me that
the hemings's were not slaves that he
would have spoken about with that
despairing a disparaging language such
as the the you know whether a woman was
a breeder or not and I think we have to
look at Jefferson's relationship to
Sally Hemings as an upstairs Downstairs
affair as an aristocrat having sex with
his servant he is of course keenly
conscious of the racial makeup of the
hemings's but I don't think that his
feelings for them are conditioned by
that other than that he feels that they
are more productive more intelligent
because they have some white blood in
them you know his prejudices are
outstanding and we have to look at
Jefferson as a slaveholder we we have to
look at the contradictions that he
represents no man has written more
eloquently about human liberty and no
man has been perhaps as blind in
resisting the the
the abolition movement I call him a
timid abolitionist because I think at
heart and certainly at the time you
wrote the Declaration of Independence
Jefferson wanted to see an end to
slavery in notes on Virginia which he
published early in his career he was
very explicit unusually explicit for his
time in laying the fault with white
America and saying that it was
inevitable that black Americans would be
free my problem though is that he didn't
grow over time he became more
conservative and he constantly
throughout his retirement years resisted
all attempts by young eager
abolitionists who solicited him who
asked for his support he invariably said
to them my generation had a chance now
it's our time is spent this is a job for
the young for a new generation but he
wouldn't lend his support to them and
that's where he failed so when I say
that Jefferson is is a father of black
disillusionment I I mean it deeply but I
don't think that the historical record
is is accurately told if we say that
well let's take Jefferson off the nickel
because he was somehow
more representative of the evil of
slavery than the many thousands of other
slaveholders
we have to we have to develop a more
balanced way of looking at Jefferson and
not allow as I write in the introduction
not allow our own emotional baggage to
overwhelm the discussion thank you all
thank you
Andrew Burstein is author of the
passions of Andrew Jackson America's
Jubilee and the inner Jefferson his
latest Jefferson Secrets is published by
basic books on the web at basic books
calm